[Music]
with so many classic scenes constantly
being added to the mcu's on-screen canon
it's getting hard to keep track of all
the best ones so we're taking a look at
the funny heartbreaking action-packed
moments in the mcu to find the most
iconic scenes from each movie
the mcu wouldn't be what it is without
iron man and the first installment of
tony stark's franchise still holds up
over a decade after it debuted from
witnessing stark cobbled together the
mark 1 suit to watching his initial
transformation from playboy to hero the
movie has a lot of moments to remember
there's one scene that stands out above
all of the rest though and it comes in
at the very end of the film as the movie
wraps up mr stark chooses to reveal his
identity to the press blurting out the
gem
truth is
i am iron man it's a surprising yet
perfect way to wrap up the introduction
to the mcu rejecting the classic secret
identity trope and embracing a new life
where superheroes take center stage
although iron man 2 admittedly took a
bit of a step back from its stellar
predecessor there's one scene in the
film that absolutely can't be overlooked
we're talking about natasha romanov's
invasion of hammer industries
headquarters while she factors in
throughout the plot as the story moves
towards its climax agent romanov shows
her true colors in a bold practically
solo assault on justin hammer's company
headquarters the scene is intense and
immediately demonstrates why the former
red room trainee warrants a coveted spot
among the super-powered ranks of the
future avengers
despite the rest of the mcu mostly
pretending it doesn't exist there are
still a few moments that are worth
remembering in the otherwise forgettable
the incredible hulk case in point the
end battle between hulk and abomination
the hulk's persona has always been
synonymous with epic destruction and the
final showdown of his solo film brings
new meaning to the word smash
as hulk and abomination crash through
harlem they upend cars destroy streets
and damage buildings the scene is
nothing short of catastrophic but it's
also a blast to watch especially since
it brings a splash of frenzied fun to an
otherwise slow-moving plot
by the end of the infinity saga thor has
been put through the ringer and has
proven himself a worthy and competent
ruler of asgard but when he was
initially introduced he was a cocky jerk
in his first eponymous film thor sparks
an interplanetary war and is exiled to
earth until he can prove himself worthy
of the station to which he was born when
he finally sacrifices his own ego and
does what's right it leads to the best
scene in the movie after being nearly
beaten by the destroyer the asgardian
finally becomes worthy to wield mjolnir
once again and it's enough to get any
fan up and out of their seat cheering
him on
although the bulk of captain america's
first film is set during world war ii it
ends up being the modern day last scene
of the film that makes the biggest
impact when steve rogers wakes up from
his 70 year long doze he finds himself
in the year 2011. as he looks around his
hospital room he realizes that
everything isn't what it seems dashing
out into the streets he's confronted by
nick fury who informs him that he's been
in an icy tomb for nearly three quarters
of a century the dramatic revelation
leaves the hero reeling but all he can
think to say is
[Music]
i had a date
considering everything that cap gave up
when he thought he was sacrificing
himself back in 1945 there's no better
way to pull on the audience's
heartstrings the avengers is the first
time we see the entire team assemble
following the various heroes as they
come together and gradually form a bond
under the watchful eye of nick fury the
movie has plenty of memorable moments
from thor and iron man duking it out in
a forest to hulk smashing loki into the
floor of stark tower however there's no
doubt that one scene stands head and
shoulders above the rest and that's the
first time the entire team is shown
together in their full colors grouped in
the streets of the big apple standing
together as they're surrounded by hordes
of chitari soldiers the scene is about
as epic as they get
relatively simple compared to many of
the flashier scenes in the mcu the sheer
intensity of the elevator fight scene in
captain america the winter soldier is
enough to sweep viewers and hydra agents
alike right off their feet seriously
outnumbered lacking proper weaponry and
giving little to no breathing room steve
rogers still manages to make short work
of his opponents the impressive close
quarters fight scene is an effective way
of reminding everyone who's watching
exactly how formidable an opponent
captain america really is
before we get started
does anyone want to get out
in the middle of thor the dark world
malagath arrives on odin's doorstep with
a squadron of soldiers searching for the
ether which resides inside of jane
foster however he's confronted by thor's
skilled mother friega who shows up as
jane's lone defender friega creates a
hologram of foster which successfully
tricks the dark elf but the queen mother
is killed in the ensuing fight it's an
impressive yet tragic end to the
character whose noble sacrifice goes on
to profoundly affect both her sons for
all of tony stark's luxuries it's when
the genius is left to operate without
his tech that he truly shines that's why
the best scene in iron man 3 has to be
when stark infiltrates the mandarin's
lair with nothing but a grab bag full of
improvised weapons the sequence is
exhilarating as one misstep or a stray
bullet could stop the armorless hero
dead in his tracks and yet his ability
to snatch a victory from the jaws of
defeat even without his armor just
reinforces why everyone loves the guy so
much
ever since the group's arrival in the
mcu back in 2014 the guardians of the
galaxy have become synonymous with
sarcastic yet effective heroism while
every single member of the gang of
misfits is lovable in their own way
groot tends to be the guy who is most
beloved by fans ever loyal willing to
sacrifice and always ready to take a
bullet for his friends it's clear that
although groot is a tree of few words he
has the heart of a hero
nowhere is this more clear than in the
best scene of guardians of the galaxy
giving his own life by growing a living
cocoon around his friends as they
hurtled through the air over zandar
groot's final words deviated ever so
slightly from his typical catch-all
phrase when he told his friends
[Music]
it was a scene that left both his
friends and the audience in tears and
served as a defining moment for the
endearing character
for all the excitement during avengers
age of ultron it ends up being the
mid-credit scene that sticks in the
minds of viewers more than anything else
why because it showcases thanos and his
infinity gauntlet for the first time
as the dust is still settling from the
battle of ultron the credits fade in on
the mad titan putting on a stoneless
gauntlet and announcing
fine
i'll do it myself
at the time of the film's release it
left fans out of their minds with
anticipation for the approaching
conflict and set the stage for the
dramatic final act of the infinity saga
while scott lang's movies are fun they
always felt a bit disconnected from the
greater narrative of the mcu at least
until end game came along when lang
rolled up to avengers headquarters with
the quantum van in tow it completely
rewrote the importance of ant-man's role
in the mcu it also made one already
iconic scene from his first movie
particularly important the moment when
lang purposefully shrinks into the
quantum realm desperate to take out
yellowjacket before he hurts lang's
daughter cassie ant-man attacks him by
shrinking between the molecules of his
suit sabotaging the yellowjacket suit
before lang shrinks away into near
nothingness a moment later he finds
himself facing an eternity of lonely
existence in the quantum realm
fortunately he messes with his regulator
and manages to escape in the nick of
time the scene isn't just iconic due to
lang's close brush with self-sacrifice
it also gives us our first glimpse into
a world that would ultimately be pivotal
in saving half of the universe
despite being the third movie in the
captain america trilogy captain america
civil war functions almost more like an
avengers film the epic film contains a
massive number of crossover appearances
including most of the avengers with the
focus throughout the film clearly on the
group rather than on cap himself it only
makes sense that the most iconic scene
would be one that involves everyone at
once when team cap faces off against
team iron man at the airport it marks
one of the few times in the mcu that we
see so many heroes suited up on the same
battlefield it's also the only time we
see groups of heroes fighting each other
and the matchups range from entertaining
to heartbreaking for all these reasons
the battle stands out as not only a
tragic yet epic event within that film
but as one of the most iconic moments in
the entire mcu
once t'challa's cousin killmonger
arrives on the scene in black panther
all eyes are fixed on the antagonist
brutal strong and possessing a tragic
backstory killmonger quickly becomes one
of the most popular villains in all of
the mcu he manages to wrestle power from
t'challa only to lose it in an epic
combat deep in the minds of wakanda the
duel ends with killmonger defeated but
t'challa graceful in victory brings him
out to witness the beauty of wakanda
rejecting t'challa's offer to attempt to
heal him killmonger chooses to bleed out
leaving his cousin with these powerful
and memorable final words just bury me
in the ocean
with my ancestors that jump from the
ships
because they knew death
was better than bondage
in spider-man homecoming the webb
slinger's first mcu solo movie perfectly
portrays peter as a friendly
neighborhood spider-man while also
expertly continuing to weave him into
the greater mcu story this is never on
better display than when parker is
confronted by tony stark on a rooftop
high over new york city in the scene
stark arrives in his iron man's suit to
chastise peter for his reckless behavior
which also demonstrates tony's own
ongoing struggle with the sokovia
accords
eventually he informs his young protege
that things aren't working out and he'll
need to return his suit when peter
blurts out that he's nothing without his
apparel stark emotionally replies
if you're nothing without this suit then
you shouldn't have it the encounter
leaves peter crushed but also forces him
to come into his own as a hero making it
one of the most pivotal scenes in the
movie
throughout guardians of the galaxy vol 2
the space pirate yondu gradually makes a
180 degree turn from his
characterization in the first film
shifting from quill's estranged father
figure to an official member of the team
however his time as a guardian of the
galaxy is short-lived soon after he
helps quill take down ego yondu gives
himself up in order to save his adopted
son from suffocating in space yondu's
sacrifice is honored with an extravagant
funeral scene in which other ravager
factions arrive unexpectedly to
celebrate their former colleague and
honor his memory several of the faction
leaders are shown giving farewell
addresses and space fireworks are fired
off in plenty the iconic scene is a
fitting testament to yondu's impact on
the guardian storyline
while heroes like the avengers and the
guardians of the galaxy spend their time
saving the physical universe from
disaster doctor strange tends to operate
on a different playing field the master
of the mystic arts stays busy combing
through time and space to ensure that
the infinite versions of the multiverse
are safe and secure which leads to the
most iconic scene in his first film his
confrontation with dormammu strange's
duel with the being from the dark
dimension differs from typical mcu
battles and how it relies on strange's
wits rather than his physical strength
strange keeps dormammu in a time loop by
dying over and over again refusing to
release him until dormammu agrees to his
terms it's the perfect demonstration of
how dramatically different strange's
tactics are from the other heroes of the
mcu as he guards so many worlds from
imminent disaster
in a film full of noteworthy scenes the
standout moment has to be when thor is
pitted against the grandmaster's
champion in a gladiatorial ring and it
turns out to be the hulk thor's reaction
to discovering the identity of his
opponent is instantly iconic with the
god of thunder yelling hey
hey
we know each other he's a friend from
work
from there the two avengers tumble
around the arena in a rowdy free-for-all
that leaves the audience thoroughly
entertained between the genius
reintroduction of hulk after he went
missing at the end of age of ultron and
the over-the-top gladiator setting the
entertaining scene became the most
memorable part of the movie from start
to finish avengers infinity war is
filled with heroes and excitement but
amidst all of the desperate action the
hilarious one-liners and the incredible
team-ups it's the shocking ending of the
film that stands out as easily the most
iconic the entire plot of infinity war
revolves around the avengers and the
guardians of the galaxy doing their best
to stop thanos from pulling off his mad
crusade to collect the infinity stones
and wipe out half of the universe but
despite the avengers valiant attempts to
stop him the mad titan actually succeeds
in his quest killing multiple heroes in
the process as half of life in the
universe fades away with the surviving
heroes helplessly looking on in horror
it's hard to process the cold inevitable
truth
he did it
surprisingly when it comes to ant-man
and the wasp it isn't the numerous trips
into the quantum realm that stand out
the most it's the after credit scene
with the movie releasing between
infinity war and end game the question
on everyone's mind was how it all fits
into the larger mcu narrative the
question is left unaddressed until the
credits begin to roll at that point we
get a quick scene in which lang heads
down to the quantum realm for a short
mission little does he realize this is
the exact moment that the snap takes
place leaving lang stuck in the quantum
realm for the next five years
although carol danvers first movie
released between infinity war and
endgame it actually takes place a few
decades earlier in the 1990s for most of
the film danvers origin remains a
mystery shrouded in an amnestic blur
that isn't resolved until later in the
film all of this makes for a fun ride as
carol embarks on a journey that slowly
leads to her taking up her mantle as a
genuine superhero the climax comes when
carol blown off of cree commander yan
rogg's ship hurtles through the
atmosphere plummeting towards the ground
below with seconds until impact carol
shuts her eyes and finally unleashes her
full power revealing exactly why nick
fury was so desperate to signal her
during his final few moments in infinity
war
from steve rogers wielding mjolnir to
the deaths of two original avengers
avengers end game is so packed with
memorable moments that it's hard to
decide which one is the most iconic
however despite the high bar there's one
scene that manages to rise above the
rest hinted at throughout the avengers
franchise one of the most highly
anticipated phrases from the comics was
initially teased in the final act of
avengers age of ultron when captain
america looked down at his new recruits
and said
avengers
the unfinished phrase left die hard
marvel fans in a tizzy until endgame
finally soothed their pain as the
climactic end battle kicks off and the
avengers and their allies pour through
portals all over the battlefield captain
america finally gets to utter the
long-awaited line with an immensely
satisfying
avengers
assemble
with the thanos narrative in the rear
view mirror the mcu came back down to
earth to wrap things up in spider-man
far from home the film served as a
fitting coda to the massive infinity
saga as it showed peter parker
processing the loss of his mentor tony
stark while understanding that it was
time to move on to the next adventure
once again it's the final moments of the
film that tend to linger most with
viewers as he swings through new york on
a date with mj peter is suddenly
confronted with a news report that
reveals his secret identity but the most
shocking element of the report is who
delivers it j jonah jameson played by
j.k simmons reprising his role from sam
raimi's spider-man trilogy what simmons
appearance means for the rest of the mcu
remains to be seen but the unexpected
twist instantly made his cameo the most
iconic part of the entire movie
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Applause]
[Music]